September 25th, 1967.
A thor-agena rocket carrying a Corona
satellite takes to the skies from Vandenberg
Air Force Base in California.
Corona is an amazing program for its day.
Launching something into space period was a
brand new concept.
It was a real game changer because now it
allowed American spy satellites to traverse
airspace undetected and take very high
resolution photographs of anything they
wanted to.
Two years into its mission as the spy bird
scans western Poland, it captures this image.
Among this really heavily wooded forest are
concrete structures.
This looks like a whole complex, almost like
a mini city here.
The fact that a spy satellite was designated
to photograph this means it ain't no Girl
Scout camp. We're probably looking at
something that was of significant national
security interest to the United States
military.
Yet declassified CIA documents reveal the
massive structures baffled their top
analysts. Investigators turned to recent
satellite images.
It just deepens the mystery as far as I'm
concerned.
In one era, these structures are visible to
satellites.
And in another the forest has reclaimed them
and overgrown them.
What is under these trees?
Why did somebody build something so big and
then just abandon it for decades?
Intrigued by what could lie in the forest.
Polish archaeologist Gregor Kikvidze is
traveling to the site in the satellite
images.
Something could be concealed in the dense
forest.
Then it raises the question about why CIA
was interested specifically in that place.
To find out. I need to go there and see what
features survived until the present day.
Archaeologist Gregor Kaiafas is in the
forests of Poland, searching for a long lost
Soviet compound, rediscovered using new
aerial images.
This is one of the structures that was
visible on the classified satellite imagery.
Cia files reveal the purpose of these
structures baffled intelligence agents during
the Cold War. Kochavi's hopes a narrow
entranceway he's found will help solve the
mystery. Oh, wow.
The structures discovered from the air
appear to be just a small part of a massive
subterranean compound.
This is incredible.
That looks like a diesel tank.
Whatever was once here is long gone.
But it appears to have been manned and
guarded by a huge number of people.
That would be septic tank.
And bathroom.
So that would be the main electrical room.
There's some wires still can be seen hanging
from the floor.
One of the larger rooms yields clues to what
the Russians were doing here.
And at the both sides of this room, there
were very thick blast proof doors.
And there are some relics of a ventilation
system.
Whatever was kept here required very
specific conditions.
The temperature and the humidity had to be
controlled for all the time.
In a blast proof chamber, the archaeologists
spot some artifacts on the floor.
Okay, so those are seals.
As an expert of the Cold War, Chvez thinks he
recognizes this type of seal.
I'm pretty sure that those were used to seal
containers with nuclear warheads.
He visits aerial data has uncovered a secret
facility capable of securing a massive
stockpile of the most devastating weapons
known to mankind.
But something about the size and shape of
the missiles kept here is unusual.
The storage rooms are actually quite small,
which tells me that they could be used only
for storage of tactical nuclear warheads.
Tactical nuclear weapons can unleash a
destructive force 20 times more powerful than
the bomb that destroyed Hiroshima.
But what's even more terrifying is how
they're used.
The Cold War is well known for the threat of
the use of nuclear weapons.
The tactical nuclear weapon would be used in
the presence of your own troops on a
battlefield.
The use of tactical nuclear weapons on a
battlefield is almost unimaginable.
With the push of a button, commanders
devastate key targets before deploying
thousands of troops to fight it out on an
apocalyptic radioactive landscape.
Imagine the reality of combat where everyone
is from head to toe in their nuclear
protective suits using machine guns, and
they're lobbing tactical nuclear weapons at
one another. All the while.
Recovered. Cold War files reveal that in the
late 1960s, the Kremlin secretly moved dozens
of nuclear missiles to the site in the
image.
Just a few hundred miles from the Soviet
controlled border with Western Europe.
They disguise the missile bunkers and
surround the compound with barracks housing
young families.
The Soviet Union wasn't stupid.
They knew that we were watching.
The Soviets work hard to make this look like
just an ordinary military base, concealing
the fact that there are tactical nuclear
weapons stored all over the place.
It was well hidden in the woods, and it was
well kept from the people who lived nearby.
From here, it seems the communists intended
to wage nuclear war.
The war to end all wars.
Yet. Kiyoshi Viz's investigation reveals
that this is just one element of the Soviet
subterfuge. This was a true Armageddon
bunker.
Just proof that there was nuclear weapon kept
within the territories of Poland and also
proof that people lived once in the shade of
nuclear holocaust.
For over three decades.
The secret site remains primed to unleash
nuclear hell on European cities and American
bases just over the border.
They have no idea that in the woods there are
all these nuclear weapons, and so their lives
could change like that in one moment.
Following the collapse of the Soviet Union,
the Soviet soldiers and their families
abandoned the site, leaving the area strewn
with their belongings and equipment.
Over the following years.
The clandestine base is reclaimed by the
forest, only to be revealed from the skies
once more.
The truth about this facility has only just
emerged.
And it makes me wonder.
What else is out there?